jean genet était un proche de simone de
beauvoir par l'amitié des idées et du
coeur jeune et beau voir ses terres en
comptant 44 à la terrasse du café de
flore tous vos journaux de ce matin tous
les médias reviennent sur la mort de
simone de beauvoir tant sa présence dans
le siècle était importante écoutez
maintenant ce témoignage de françoise
verny aujourd'hui aux éditions gallimard
elle aimait simone de beauvoir je
l'aimais beaucoup il ya une chose qui
m'avait toujours impressionné chez elle
c'est que c'était une femme de très
grande intelligence et d'une très grande
rigueur intellectuelle
et puis que c'est tout de même une femme
absolument étonnante quand on pense à la
vie qui fut la sienne à la fois sur 9
mai à ce qu'elle a fait avec sartre à
cette sorte de longue complicité je
pense que le couple sartre beauvoir si
beaucoup plus important que le couple
aragon et elsa triolet parce que c'est
juste un coup punis par des sentiments
mais lui aussi par une sorte de
formidable complicité intellectuelle et
tout ça je ne sais pas quand on pense à
ces magnifiques lettres aux casteurs que
simon nous voit puisque c'est ainsi que
sartre rappelé simon de pouvoir le
casteur quand on pense qu il avait avec
une complicité tel qui lui parlait même
des autres femmes qu'il rencontrait je
trouve que c'est une histoire aussi
étonnantes et son combat pour les femmes
et bien sûr qu'on bat paul est à vous -
m'a beaucoup intéressé gt4 émission avec
elle c'est au tour du deuxième sexe je
crois que son combat pour les femmes il
comprend jamais bien quand elle est le
deuxième sexe en 1949 ça n'était pas un
pamphlet c'était une sorte de du constat
existentielles sur la condition des
femmes et je crois qu'elle est restée
jusqu'au bout extraordinairement
vigilante sur le problème du combat des
familles c'est à dire c'est à dire que
c'était le combat qu'elle a mené même
après la mort de siv qu'elle continue
elle continue à s'occuper auprès de
madame oudjit d'un certain nombre de
choses et elle continue aussi à
s'occuper par exemple du centre flora
tristan qui s'occupe des femmes battues
et de continuer à être très très
attentive au sort des femmes dans le
monde entier à votre avis qu'est-ce
qu'on va retenir d'elle l'avenir
va retenir delplanque chaud au jeu va
retenir d'elle cette formidable
complicité avec ça c'était deux très
grands témoins des monstres comme dans
l'église de plus et que je vais retenir
d'elle cette oeuvre comme ça c'est neuf
qui est un tel témoignage sur notre
époque